- I would definitely
consider myself a Democrat.
- I too, do think we're
gonna well on this?
- No.
- [Man] No.
- No, we're gonna suck.
- I would agree.
(funky music)
- [Voiceover] "People in
urban America have got to
"appreciate that the
overwhelming majority of
"people who hunt know about
guns and respect guns,
"and are law-abiding
people, that's the truth."
- I feel like it might be
him, 'cause he's from Vermont,
so there's probably a lot more hunters.
- Saying urban is kinda old school.
- It's really old school,
it's kind of offensive too,
which both would, I mean..
- I feel like that's a Hilary statement.
The word urban, slightly out of touch.
- I think that was Hilary.
- [Man] Bernie.
- I'm gone say it was Bermie.
- I'm gonna say, I'm feeling pretty Bern.
(bell rings)
- We're off to a great start.
- [Woman] Oh no.
(hands smacking)
- [Voiceover] "I would
create the first ever
"Office of Immigrant Affairs."
- That's not an office yet?
- Talking about creating something
that's never happened before,
not worrying about a budget whatsoever.
- But also going for bureaucracy.
- I don't know, I feel
like they both say that.
- He keep attacking her about the kids.
I feel like that was a
thing in one of the debates.
- I'm gonna go Hilary then,
only 'cause you going Hilary.
- [Man] Bermie.
- I'm gonna say
it's a Hilary thing to say to be like,
"I'm gonna make another
form of government."
- So, I was gonna say it was Bernie.
(bell rings)
- I win!
(man laughs)
- She's not like, "I'm gonna
end racism", like this guy,
(man laughs)
She's gonna be like, "I'm
gonna make a department
"to address this issue."
- That sounds political.
- [Voiceover] "Let us wage
a moral and political war
"against war itself, so that
we can cut military spending
"and use that money for human needs."
- I don't think Hilary would be like,
"Let's cut military spending."
- Hilary is like, "We gotta bomb 'em up."
- That's Obama.
- I don't think so, it was her.
- [Man] I..
(woman befuddled)
- I'm choosing the Bern.
- Read it to me one more time?
- You, oooh!
(bell rings)
- [Woman] Yaay!
- Dammit.
- Wuuss.
- If it's specific, you go with Hilary,
if it's not specific, then it's just like,
"Let's just save everyone."
- So you've got an algorithm for this
the whole time?
- [Woman] I do.
- [Voiceover] "We're asking the top 1 1/2%
"including passive income to start paying
"a little bit more so that
the elderly and disabled vets
"in this country can live
with security and dignity."
- I feel like that
could be either as well.
- The 1%'s very Bernie,
but I feel like him saying
for them to pay a little bit
more is not enough for him.
- It's only about old people.
- Yo, but they're both pretty old, dude.
- I'm gonna say Hilary.
- Hilary will be with us for another
300 years.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- So I'll follow you.
- But she's specific, she talk about vets.
I think it's also Hilary.
- Bernie.
(bell rings)
- [Man] Ohh.
- Ooh.
- Wooo, I see you.
- [Woman] Yaay!
- Yes.
- [Voiceover] "No other
country can rally the world
"to defeat ISIS and win the generational
"struggle against radical jihadism."
- [Woman] Foreign wuss.
- Well, Hilary Clinton was
our Secretary of State.
When Hilary Clinton was in the room like,
- Yeah, she was like,
when they were shooting
up Osama bin Laden.
- [Man] Hilary.
- Hilary.
- Bernie.
- She knows about her external affairs.
- Yeah.
(bell rings)
- [Woman] Uhh!
- Mmmm!
- Hilary point please.
- I feel like I did horribly.
A lot of the statements
that I thought for sure
were Bernie, turned out to
be Hilary and vise versa.
- I feel like I learned a
lot about my politicians,
and learned about their
different types of rhetoric.
- I think what's been
tough about this election
is there's just been so much yelling
through the media happening
and so many outrageous things,
that gets really hard to
cut through all of that
and listen to actually what
policies are being proposed.
- I think they should just
hold hands and run together.
- Y'all should kiss. (smacks lips)
I wanna kiss her. (smacks lips)
I wanna be her friend forever.